an app for rich people who only want to
date rich people gingers new update is
forcing people over 30 to shell out
nearly $20 a month for its premium
service but that's likely chump change
for the users of Luxy a new premium
dating app for rich people or as their
spokesperson put it it works a lot like
tinder except this is tinder - the for
people in order to join the app men must
make at least 250,000 dollars a year and
must be verified with tax records while
women just have to be attractive all
right so men have to be rich women just
have to be attractive this feels really
gross to me yeah viscerally it really
upsets me but at the same time if
there's a market there's a market right
already there exists the right stuff
which is one that the only reason I know
it is my ex-boyfriends dad used it only
for Ivy Leaguers there's one that's just
for Harvard guys all about this guy
here's the thing people care about
different things in their mate and like
figure out what matters to you and then
find that and if you can like sort
through it really quickly then Who am I
to be like go through a lot of other
things so Molly's all for that so but to
her point so this is just technology
going to where people have needs right
if guys that have a lot of money you
want to meet hot girls well then there's
that but you also know if you're that
guy that you're just meeting girls who
are only wanting to meet those rich guys
anyway so it is a there is a self
selection process but you know it's nice
than like JDate or different than like
what's the farmers friends matters to
you then you're gonna a lot of farmers
in one very source sheep sorry like
anyway people self-select on tinder for
other superficial sort more superficial
things even if they're tall if they're
you know white or black or whatever else
if they're you know fat or skinny or
like people self-select for that anyway
it's only a matter of time before like
these very niche dating sites get even
more niche and people like go for what
they know they like do you guys think
we're like taking something very
important very tan
out of the love equation like where
people used to maybe meet at a bar not
that that's the most loving place on
earth but you would meet someone just on
a walk on a bike ride and now it's like
we have it all pre-selected right in
front of do you think we're actually
losing something that's very human I
mean I think we're losing I think we're
losing something from all social media
is right now I mean all of our
interactions and how we're hanging with
our friends it all happens on Instagram
and snapchat and Twitter so yeah I mean
we want everybody to go outside and meet
each other and go to the library the
kids go to the library anymore these
days no yeah I never understood the
library your told me you're just gonna
give me a book and just trust me that
I'm gonna bring it back we go to the
library whatever you like I think that
you know I don't know that that we're
necessarily losing things I think we're
just looking for things in different
places now right the friends that I have
that are with people that they met
online aren't in any less loving or
fulfilling relationships than the ones
who met in the real world you know I
think that certainly things are changing
whether or not normatively that's good
or bad it remains to be seen but I I
don't think I'm agnostic I don't think
that there is a that it is wrong in and
of itself to be finding something right
so it's sort of however you use it and
incorporate it into your life I'll go
with that
final thought on this how important is
your phone to your day-to-day life
because almost every story that we've
covered for the last two years is
somehow always related back to this
thing that we're walking around like how
important is that thing to you you know
I just had my phone we were together in
Haiti and I had my phone stolen and I
had two days without having a phone and
it was it was some of the best days of
my life I loved it so yeah my phone is
how often did you go to your pocket in
well I go I go all the time and I've now
I have a new rule where the phone isn't
in my bedroom or the phone doesn't exist
in that place so at least there's no
first thing in the morning last thing at
night but I have to set a lot of rules
for my phone it's it's more boundaries
and I have my point about you your phone
is right there so I know it's like sort
of I'm like don't touch that thing my
boyfriend is a joke that as soon as they
have phone implants for you that I'm
gonna be there for the first customer of
that because I'm always on it according
to him but yeah I am I mean I think
they're
this sort certainly a lack of separation
between work and life at least for us
right because you're in the startup
world and you're you're constantly
feeling like your personal brand and
identity is linked with this thing that
you're building and for us and Riots
case it's an extra Keable in a lot of
ways and so the idea that you're
building the company from anywhere is
really exciting but it also means that
maybe you're not experiencing everywhere
so you sort of gave us an excuse that we
can be on our alright well I want to
thank Molly and Bryn not only for being
the first guest on the Reuben Court but
for bringing me and making me home here
at riot I'm extremely excited so all the
stories that we covered this week we're
all source from Riot org you can see
them in the links below and that's where
you can take the action and we have a
ton a ton of stuff coming up for you
guys
we got big celebrities we're gonna be
going out in the field more we're gonna
be bringing some interesting new people
and here anything else that I might be
forgetting there's gonna be ways to take
action and there's gonna be a lot of
ways to take and also that final thought
that you're gonna bring us home on right
we're gonna have birthday parties for
everybody birthday parties for everybody
alright thanks for watching guys we'll
do it again